okay so I started at Desert Breeze
Community Center where it was a steady
stream of people but I want you to take
a look and also you can see a car is
trying to just get by there is a huge
line here at Centennial Center in the
Northwest Valley as people are patiently
waiting making sure they get their final
vote in before November 8th
this morning I believe we were at about
163 000 who had voted in the past 13
days so as I mentioned previously
today's probably going to be the busiest
day out of all 14 days of voting It's
the final rush to early vote register
our voters Joe Gloria tells me they've
seen 3 700 voters walk in and cast their
ballot and that was just at 11 Friday
morning Centennial Center is the busiest
of the early voting locations in the
valley with lines moving at a swift Pace
while Scott and Jennifer Brown decided
to do the mail-in drop-off ballot option
well we ran out of time filling it out
and researching the candidates and so
today was the last day so we wanted to
get it in today to avoid the crowds on
Tuesday I think just that it is a very
different time and there are so many
important issues going on right now and
it just feels extra important to give my
voice and make sure I stand up for the
things that I want to see happen and the
people I believe will make that happen
and the difference this year when it
comes to mail-in ballots has far
surpassed in-person voting overall the
dynamic has changed in voting in Clark
County without a doubt as a result of
mail being sent to All voters except for
those who opted out there are definitely
more male voters who have sent their
ballots back to be processed then all of
the early voting
um in-person churnout the numbers are
higher in the mail it's over two hundred
thousand
people can still mail in or drop off
their ballot anytime through Tuesday now
as long as there is a line here the
Centennial Center location will stay
open they are slated to close at 8 pm
but again the line keeps on growing so
if you want to go out there and make
your vote tonight come on out to
Centennial Center where you can cast
your vote up until 8 PM reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now